vous avez pu parler aux policiers de val
d'or mais d'abord sur cette pétition là
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous en pensez
parce que la ministre comme beaucoup de
gens a été choquée par ce qu'elle a
entendu jeudi soir on peut pas lui
reprocher ça quand même nom ont opté
pour ce qui est de la pétition on est
homo mis au courant ce matin j'ai pas lu
j'ai pas eu la chance de lire la
pétition parce que ça va très vite
depuis ce matin je sais la teneur par
contre comme tout le monde
ce n'est pas une demande syndicale c'est
un geste spontané qui s'est fait sur les
réseaux sociaux
je ne compte pas déjà zidane au
contraire mais il faut comprendre il
faut comprendre que les policiers sont
en état de choc un peu de parler les
réactions dans ce dossier l'eau est
moins dans mon communiqué de presse
je tends la main la ministre pour
qu'elle puisse au moins réitéré sa
confiance envers les policiers
l'ensemble des policiers de la sûreté du
québec je pense que c'est important mais
je pense que personne n'a remis la
compétence et le travail de l'ensemble
des policiers du québec
mais ce que les gens ont demandé puis ce
qui a été fait vendredi matin c'est que
les policiers ciblées soit mis de côté
avec salaires en passant donc soit
suspendu vous êtes contre ce geste là
c'est pas une prudence élémentaire de
les suspendre
c'est une prérogative du directeur
général je crois qu'il a utilisé ses
pouvoirs
comme il se fait dans plusieurs enquêtes
au niveau de certaines allégations de
nature criminelle
surtout quand c'est des allégations d'un
tribunal contre la personne
ça arrive fréquemment ya 30% des
dossiers se font naturellement de jean
l'eau donc j'espère contre le fait que
le directeur
vous n'êtes pas contre le fait qu'on les
ait suspendu n'ont elles pas
nécessairement et je peux pas dire que
je suis pauvre mais non je ne suis pas
content c'est usuelles et naturellement
c'est en sachet dans les relations de
travail
c'est en sachet dans des dents des dents
des codes de procédure al interne chez
nous et c'est usuels donc on fera valoir
les droits en temps et lieu mais on en
est pas là encore qu'est ce que les
policiers de la sq eu de val-d'or que
vous avez pu rencontrer cet après midi
vous ont dit qu'est ce qui les choque
qu'est-ce que sur une son pop plutôt les
gestes de leurs ex ou collègues qui
devrait les choquer plutôt que le fait
qu'on rende son public depuis jeudi et
plus pour un policier
lorsqu'on enquête nous on parle
d'allégations
on est sur le pas aux confusions par
rapport au juste je pense que dans les
sites là dans la tête de tous les
policiers il s'agit d'allégations on va
laisser le temps aux enquêtes de se
faire de faire la lumière là dessus et
si les accusations
les membres en question devront se
défendre devront se représenter et on
verra qu'est ce qui va avoir au bout du
compte je pense que les policiers j'ai
rencontré aujourd'hui son sont face à
une situation qui est difficile à
résoudre
par rapport à leur travail ils sont sans
ressources pour travailler auprès de ce
genre de clientèle et ils sont aussi
c'est un mélange de colère et
d'incompréhension de désarroi par
rapport à la façon dont la société en
général traiter le dossier
je pense que moi je les oui je l'aï dit
ce matin il est aussi a été traité de
façon très très émotive et on demande
juste de calmer le jeu un peu puis de
prendre un peu de recul et de travailler
maintenant de façon constructive pour
s'attaquer aux problèmes aux problèmes
autochtone qui est beaucoup plus profond
que les allégations contre les policiers
c'est une chose c'est entre bonnes mains
les enquêteurs s'en occupe maintenant je
pense qu'il faudra travailler sur
l'ensemble de la problèmatique sur
l'ensemble des problématiques
autochtones au canada parce que
effectivement l'ailé les gestes les
allégations graves et où seules les
enquêtes c'est une chose vous dit par
ailleurs et je pense tout le monde
convient de ce qui est un problème dans
les relations entre certains autochtones
la population québécoise blanche dans
une ville comme val d'or des problèmes
de toxicomanie des problèmes d'errance
et cetera
vous êtes nos policiers sont pas assez
armé pour faire face à tout ça ça prend
des ressources des gîtes et cetera
est ce que on demande ça avec un site
d'insistance où on attend des textes et
des puits de commettre des gestes
inacceptables
je pense que ça fait longtemps que les
policiers du poste de val d'or entre
autres dénoncent le manque de ressources
que ce soit suite à des coupures
budgétaires que ce soit du manque
d'effectifs que ce soit un manque de
ressources matérielles humaines mais je
pense que l'occasion on est l'occasion
rêvée aujourd'hui pour
mettre de côté un peu les émotions puis
s'attaquer au vrai problème est
d'ailleurs l'association s'est prononcé
pour une commission pancanadienne sur la
problématique autochtone en espérant
qu'on va enfin s'attaquer au problème
pierre veilleux merci de nous avoir par
les représentants des policiers et
policières du québec merci fait plaisir
monsieur